de la musique pour terminer seul à
quelques jours de la fête de la musique
qui aura lieu lundi prochain c'est à
dire le 21 juin
ce jour-là amateurs et professionnels
seront libres de s'exprimer partout dans
les rues sur les balcons dans les
casernes et j'en passe marie claire
gauthier nous dit dès à présent ce que
sera la philosophie de ce véritable
happening musical
le temps des séries 2
le gardien
alema
vainqueurs seront qu'est ce qu'un
musicien c'est d'abord un praticien
celui qui pratique les disciplines de la
musique quelle qu'elle soit ça peut être
un chanteur batteur du groupe de jazz ça
peut être un musicien d'orchestre a peut
être un compositeur de musique et même
un musicologue
ça commence ici et ça finit là
[Musique]
il
les musiciens des rues au chef adulé la
musique qui est considéré un peu partout
en occident comme le plus immatérielle
de tous les arts et le plus porteur d'
aspiration générale il y à plus de 5
millions de français qui font de la
musique
un français sur trois possèdent au moins
un instrument de musique
ça veut dire que la musique est chez
nous un véritable phénomène de société
et jusqu'ici on ne connaît que la partie
apparente de l'iceberg les grandes
institutions les vedettes mais on ne
sait pas que tant de français font de la
musique et que tant de français en ont
besoin d'en faire donc il fallait
d'abord détruire l'idée reçue que les
français ne sont pas musiciens qu'ils le
montrent
[Musique]
je
qu'elles soient divertissement ou
culture élémentaire la pratique de la
musique est avant tout un mode
d'expression mais est ce une fête
je dirais surtout rester dans un langage
et langage le plus international qui
existe parce que tout le monde d'accord
même sans avoir faim
[Musique]
karajan qui à paris c'est un événement
dans
turenne capital
on
notre si beau pays
mais depuis
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
si nous nous contenterons d'écouter la
musique deviendrions très vite un peuple
à à longues oreilles mais avoir courte
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]